hey I've already melted the lawn I know
thanks for doing that so what you want
well singing you and I go grab a burger
why because it thought it'd be a nice
thing to do which restaurant why does it
matter
well McDonald's burgers are frying
sometimes I like fine broiled fine we
can go to Burger King I don't like the
prize a Burger King always has those
Carly fries
shoot they don't have burgers then let's
go to water burger okay but I hope
you're not this cranky the whole meal
[Music]
so
never really had a chance to talk much
lately lots are so hot in here
hey C's busted why don't you get it
fixed cause I got better things spend my
money on
anyway what I wanted to say
even though I'm not loving your attitude
lately I think it's great you got this
job you're doing so well it
I'm prouder
all right that's all you have to say
maybe if I wasn't sweating my balls off
I could think of something else
stick your head out the window
if it's about money I've got money
they can even be alone if it makes you
feel better
don't you dare
I said you're proud of my job I don't
think you are no one
forget lunch let's just go smart save
some money for your truck
[Applause]
dad kicked me out of his truck I had to
walk back
what don't think did you say or do how
do you know I'm the one who did
something dumb cuz you kind of shine at
it all I did is offer to pay to fix his
AC
and there it is dumb what's wrong with
that your dad is a grown man he doesn't
want his kid giving it money so he's
glad I'm making money but I'm not
allowed to use that money to help him
out I don't get it
someday when you have a bunch of sweaty
mullet-headed kids running around you
will oh I ain't never having kids
well that's the smartest thing I ever
heard you say thank you
you made it yeah I made it
sorry
no problem
[Music]